hi everyone
my name is ricardo alvarez pimentel
and i am graduating this year with my
doctorate in history
very excited to be one of this year's
recipients of the theorem rocco field
price and i want to go ahead and begin
by congratulating my fellow winners and
what i'm sure is fantastic work
i'd also like to take a moment
to thank my doctoral advisor gilbert
joseph in the history department as well
as other members of my committee
for supporting this research before
during and after the covet 19 pandemic
lastly i want to begin by also thanking
my family who's with me here today
for supporting me ever since i set foot
on yelp campus the first year of my
graduate school program in 2014.
i couldn't have done it without any of
you so thank you
the title of my dissertation is from
secret war to cold war
race catholicism and the unmaking of
counter-revolutionary mexico
1917-1946
essentially
my dissertation explores
a counter-revolutionary religious
movement that tried to undo the
consequences of mexico's seemingly
progressive 1910 revolution
some of the legacies of this revolution
included
separation between church and state
manifested in anti-clerical policies
the mandating of secular and socialist
education for all mexican youth
the nationalization of the economy
greater rights for women and indigenous
workers etc
i study the movements that opposed all
of those measures
as spearheaded by upper class middle and
upper class catholic women and youth
groups now
my dissertation traces a very
interesting evolution of political
ideologies
beginning in 1917
i began to talk about this movement as
one that espoused and adopted
predominantly democratic and liberal
ideals in its fight against
anti-clerical authoritarianism
however
by the 1930s
we begin to see that the same movement
began to adopt authoritarian political
models and even flirt with fascism
for reasons which i will explain in just
a second
finally
by the early 1940s we begin to see a
convergence of church and state
interests and the effective end of the
counter-revolution as it integrated
itself
to the mexican post-revolutionary state
my dissertation essentially argues that
the reason for these transformations
was raised and the reason why this
movement essentially failed
was racism
my dissertation demonstrated that this
was a movement that was driven and
undone primarily by perceptions and
notions of whiteness
and it
takes religious discourse as presented
by these organizations
and analyzes the racialized dimensions
sometimes lying in the subtext
of what was being explicitly conveyed
thus
my dissertation phrases
the evolution of racism in mexican
society
just as it traces the evolution of this
counter-revolutionary movement
from a secret war that was fought
between church and state not just in
mexico but also across the atlantic
particularly in countries like spain and
the us
to a cold war that brought church and
state together
in their joint interests to suppress
working-class indigenous mobilization
i look forward to talking more about
this work throughout today tomorrow and
even after
feel free to follow me on twitter
actually at r alvarez pi
i'd like to take a moment to thank the
committee again
for rewarding my work with this
recognition
and i'd also like to take a moment to
congratulate the members of the class of
2022.
congratulations
hello i'm anna dunsing graduating with a
phd from the department of history and
african american studies
i'm a historian of the united states of
the modern world specializing in
african-american history black
internationalism in the evolving
politics of white supremacy in the
united states across the 20th century
and i'm a 2022 winner of the porter
prize for my dissertation
fascists without labels jim crow civil
rights and the making of a black
anti-fascist tradition 1933-1977
fascist without labels chronicles a
diffuse network of black radical
thinkers activists and their grassroots
multiracial coalitions as they organized
to sound alarm over homegrown fascism in
the united states initially during the
age of jim crow
in addition to identifying and combating
white supremacists who actively work to
merge fascist ideologies practices and
aesthetics with distinctly american
political traditions these figures
confronted what they identified as
undeniable parallels echoes and overlaps
between global fascism and the normal
daily functioning of politics in the
united states
my work illuminates the richness of the
black anti-fascist tradition of the
1930s and 1940s yet my research is
ultimately focused on tracking the way
these figures mobilized in the post-war
period
against fascist afterlives possessing
segregationists and their supporters
and those many lawmakers state officials
and everyday white people who remained
deeply committed to a politics of white
supremacy and to anti-black violence
even after jim crow's ostensible demise
with the civil rights triumphs of the
1960s
my dissertation offers a history of
black radicalism and modern conservatism
in conversation and in contestation
it tells the story of white supremacy
racial nationalism vigilantism and state
violence in the united states
while elevating a globally minded black
freedom struggle in which black radical
thinkers activists civil rights leaders
and everyday people
vigilantly analyzed and underscored the
practices and processes that kept
fascism alive in this country
anti-fascism i argue was a central
element of black activist struggles for
justice and liberation across the 20th
century
and it is essential history for
understanding and navigating our present
moment thanks very much for this award
and congratulations to everyone
graduating this year
hi i'm jill tan a third year phd
candidate in anthropology i study death
and dying in singapore and work with a
funeral profession
as a writer artist and researcher i am
committed to collaborative practice and
multimodal exploration through games
performance and poetics
i am a 2022 winner of the field prize
my prize submission is entitled notes on
the bicentennial of a floundering 2019
this multimedia work of hybrid poetry
which has video sculpture and
performance elements grew out of my poem
essay of the same title on british
imperialism in singapore
through this work i explore how my
subjectivity as a singaporean has
resulted in an entrenched misrecognition
of colonial violence as a birthmark
rather than a scab
as a singaporean who has been taught not
to notice how the enduring violence of
imperial corporate power structures my
way in the world i began making this
work to reflect upon 2019 as the
bicentennial of the british colonization
of singapore in 1819
this work takes several forms its origin
as poetic text voiced as part of a
soundscape and as a visually a
materially mediated archival object
wherein paper pulp is molded into
sculpture on film and in performance
in my work i explore how as a method and
expression of inquiry the poetic holds
within itself a built-in resistance to
foreclosure
i find that the poetic is a bespoke
contraption for mapping out gestures
which also embody the qualities of
research design that i seek in my
ethnographic practice as an
anthropologist
the poetic moves and is moved by the
ethnographic object in motion
following its charge can be a way of
writing and doing ethnography that
instantiates and creates it seems to
flow and force
in making this work the poetic lent the
dual modalities of accretion and
attrition and a visual rather than
textual literacy
using not only rejections and illusions
but cleavage and sequence to build my
case of a lost consciousness
as i moved through building by way of
unlearning i thought of this hybrid poem
not only as a simulacrum of archive
archival form and formulation but as an
entry in itself
i not only suggest the text status as
archival objects through formal mimesis
of a historical document but forge an
archival encounter within it by
excepting and then deconstructing my own
writings from 2009 on singapore's
national historical narratives
poetics can serve as a pushback against
the predisposition towards ossification
of the postcolonial archive that
narratives almost always feed into
without deserting the literary entirely
without as much stock placed in arc and
teleology the poetic as a contraption
for a contingent moving object
destabilizes the archive upon entry
thank you
[Music]